hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast advances in sedimentation
analysis
I am dr. Chad Schwartz senior
application scientist at Beckman Coulter
and I'll be your moderator for today's
event we're delighted to bring you this
educational webinar presented by lab
roots and sponsored by Beckman Coulter
second Coulter is a leader in six
predation and flow cytometry and has
long been an innovator and particle
characterization laboratory automation
and genomics Beckman culture products
are used at the forefront of important
areas of investigation and discovery for
more information please visit Beckman
Coulter comm we have a few important
announcements before we begin firstly
there is a blue files button at the
lower left of your screen that will
allow you to access a downloadable PDF
of the presentation secondly this
webcast is designed to be interactive
and we encourage you to ask questions
during the live event you can submit
questions by typing them in the Q&A box
which can be found at the lower left of
the presentation window we'll try to
answer as many questions as we can
additionally there will be a few poll
questions that we can ask you to answer
near the beginning of the presentation
the answers to these questions will
allow dr. Denver to gain a better grasp
on the audience's experience with
analytical ultracentrifugation if you
have any technical problems viewing or
hearing this presentation please click
on the support button at the top right
of your presentation window or submit
your problems to the green Q&A button
lower left I would now like to introduce
today's speaker
boria's dimmler dr. Dinesh started his
education at the University of Montana
Aaron earn a degree in chemistry and
mathematics he then joined Professor Ken
van hold at you Oregon State University
for his graduate studies earning a PhD
in biochemistry and biophysics with his
work involving biophysical
characterization of chromatin it was an
inductor Van holds laboratory that he
first learned about a UC in a 30 year
old Beckman modely instrument with UV
absorbance optics and a strip chart
recorder he digitized the instrument and
wrote his first version of ultra scan to
analyze a UC experiment
next he moved to Texas to join Professor
Jeff's Hamptons laboratory at the
University of Texas Health Science
Center in San Antonio for a postdoctoral
position where he poured it ultra scan
to his to the ex la XLI
instruments after completed in
completing his postdocs he joined the
biochemistry faculty at UT HSC San
Antonio and became director for the
Center for analytical
ultracentrifugation of macromolecule
assemblies which he still manages today
I am delighted to now turn it over to
dr. demo for his presentation
hello everybody good morning and thanks
for joining I want to also thank dr.
Schwartz for introducing me today's
seminar will be on sedimentation
analysis I will tell you a little bit
about what we're doing in our lab in
order to improve ultra scan software
package for the analysis of AEC data and
tells you what methods we have
implemented recently to address specific
problems in biology and nanoscience my
talk will cover the following topics
first of all give you a background and I
will on touch on the parameters that we
can pull out of a UC experiments on size
anisotropy and density and discuss
optimization methods on that are
implemented in ultra scan um I will
focus on two different classes of
analysis methods one dealing with non
interacting systems and those that deal
with interacting systems and I will
present examples to illustrate what I
would on what we're presenting here so
first what can we learn from analytical
ultrason a UC is an excellent method for
characterizing any molecule you can put
into a solution you can study their
interactions and you can do it in the
solution environment with very very
small amount of sample it only needs
about half a mil in order to study it in
the AEC and you can run up to 14 samples
at at the same time the analysis is
based on first principles which means
that we know mathematical equations
describe everything that goes on inside
of the ultracentrifuge cell and so we
don't need any standards like you would
need in column chromatography we also
have much higher resolution than for
example in light scattering the
molecules can study in the physiological
environment so if you deal with proteins
and DNA and other biomolecules it
sometimes important to be able to
modulate the solution conditions so you
can study the effect of pH ionic
strength
what kind of buffer you're using you can
even study things like oxidation state
by adding reductant you can add ligands
such as drugs and see what they do to
your samples you can modulate
temperature and you can modulate
concentration in all of these things
turn out to be very useful when you
study biological samples furthermore by
mod by changing the speed with which you
run your experiment you have access to a
very large size range of molecules you
can study anywhere from a few hundred
dollars up to tens or hundreds of
millions of dollars can be studied
because we're measuring in the solution
environment we also have access to the
dynamics of the system so you can
measure oligomerization States
reversible self or hetero associating
systems we can measure the stoichiometry
you can measure ligand binding and you
can even measure the slow kinetics on
that may be involved in the reaction as
well as the equilibrium constants
another application is to study the
composition of samples maybe you have an
unknown sample you don't really know
what the composition is then you can get
access to the number of components that
partial concentrations molecular weight
size and anisotropy finally you can get
access to the shape of the molecule at
least indirectly by doing conformational
analysis such as like folding and
melting studies of biopolymers
conformational changes that are induced
by changes in the solution properties
here's a quick review of the
experimental setup you have a rota that
can be spun up to 60,000 rpm generating
up to about 300 G 300,000 G which is a
pretty high force making even small
molecule settlement
the sample is contained in the sample
compartment like you see here on the
Left which is scepter shape so the flow
goes with the sector shape of the of the
compartment we don't have any more wall
effects we have a meniscus at the top of
the solution column and we from moving
boundary during the sedimentation
process that you can track by adding on
light or by scanning so with some
wavelengths that could be either UV or
visible or using Rayleigh interference
optics or fluorescence the light that
gets absorbed by the sample can be
measured on captured below by a camera
and you get an observance trace that
shows you are a meniscus at the top
which is sort of a refractive artifact
giving you spike and then you see them
the moving boundary that sediments and
diffuses at the same time and you see
the concentration arm represented as an
absorption trace you make these
measurements these scans over time you
do multiple scans generating a data set
that looks like this blue one here where
you have multiple traces showing you
what the concentration distribution
looks like over time
when we start on everything is uniformly
distributed throughout the cell so it's
red is our analyte here on it is
uniformly mixed throughout the sound we
get a horizontal scan on our horizontal
line showing uniform observance with
cell but as soon as we spin up the rotor
we form a moving boundary and you see
depletion near the meniscus where there
is no longer any observance and then you
see this moving boundary which also
diffuses
and this whole process is described by
the lam equation which you see here up
on top and on the second order partial
differential equation which you can
solve using finite element and the thing
that I want to point out here is that
you have a sedimentation term describing
the sedimentation transport inside of
the cell circled in blue and you have a
diffusion term which describes how
boundary that you create diffuses over
time to calibrate that concentration
gradient if you go to the end of the
experiment on you have an equilibrium
condition in which the sedimentation and
diffusion terms cancel out and are no
more net flow occurs and when you solve
this differential equation all the time
terms drop out and you end up with an
exponential and you see an exponential
trace the slope of the exponent on the
slope of this exponential shape is then
proportional to the molecular weight so
when we fit the Lamb equation to our
experimental data we essentially get two
pieces of information one is a
sedimentation coefficient and the other
is a diffusion coefficient and we get
that for each analyte that's in the
mixture these parameters once we have
obtained them can be used to obtain
additional details about the sample so
for example we can take the diffusion
coefficient and plug it into this
equation to get the frictional
coefficient of our sample similarly the
s value that we get the sedimentation
coefficient together with the frictional
coefficient can be used in in this
equation to obtain the molecular weight
this also requires knowledge of the
partial specific volume and it requires
knowledge of the density of the solvent
in which we are measuring once we have
the molecular weight together with the
partial specific volume we can also
obtain the volume of the molecule once
we have the volume of the molecule we
can determine the radius of a equivalent
sphere
we call that our zero if we plug the r0
into the Stokes Einstein relationship
second to the last equation shown here
you can obtain the frictional
coefficient of the equivalent sphere
together the frictional coefficient
obtained in the first equation and and
the equivalent sphere frictional
coefficient make up the frictional ratio
which gives us the anisotropy which I
then denote by five this will give us an
idea about the gloved lyrically of this
animal and tell us something about the
shape so what we get then is we get some
information about the shape of the
molecule we get some information about
the size and we get some idea about the
anisotropy of the particle which is also
related to the shape and then there's
this density dependence over here where
we have on information about the partial
specific volume of the molecule and the
density now please note that we can only
get two parameters out at any given time
the third one needs to be supplied and
ordinarily this is our partial specific
volume the density of the solvent can be
measured independently and provided
through third third methods now in a non
interacting system on such as this one
you can see we have multiple boundaries
are we add the Lamb equations together
and multiply each lamb equation for each
component that's in system by some
amplitude CI okay so the C island
represents the partial concentration of
a solute in an interacting system the
situation is a little different and here
the sedimentation diffusion coefficient
is not constant throughout the
experiment but it is dependent on the
mass action equation off whatever
reaction is occurring so for example if
you have a mon with dynamic equilibrium
as shown here we can get the association
constant by dividing the concentration
of the dimer by the concentration of the
monomer squared now the Ray
she loved diamond versus monomers
dependent on the concentration inside of
that moving boundary gradient that we
have so at the top of the gradient we
have more higher concentration so we get
more diamond in at the bottom the
diamond will fall apart into monomer at
low concentration and be mostly monomer
so what we're measuring then is weight
average sedimentation coefficient shown
here and the gradient average diffusion
coefficients for all species that are in
the mixture and so we just modify our
land equation to fit the gradient
average diffusion and the weight average
sedimentation coefficient in the case
like that and I will then on show you
methods for how we can access this
information for each one of those
systems so we have a velocity experiment
and we can ask questions such as how
many components are in there what are
their sizes and then molecular weight
what are the anisotropies what are the
partial concentrations and do these
components interact and if so how fast
and how strongly do they interact and
then finally we want to know what's the
reliability of our measurements so we
want to get some statistics we have
several methods for analyzing the data
that comes back from the analytical
ultracentrifugation to two-dimensional
spectrum analysis or to DSA which gives
us a high-resolution general and model
independent solution for both sides and
anisotropy distributions of non intact
existence next there's a parametrically
constraint spectrum analysis or PCA
which is similar in the way to the to
GSA in that it's identify size
anisotropy relationships but here for
polymerizing glamourizing systems and it
provides provides constraint set over
the two-dimensional sedimentation
diffusion space there's also custom grid
analysis where we can take advantage of
prior knowledge that may have from
another experiment we use that to
constrain our data set and parameterize
the tds a grid in terms of
alternate hydrodynamic variables we have
the genetic algorithms which is a an
optimization method which will give us
robust nonlinear least squares
optimization and trade provides in
parsimonious regularization of the
tedious a spectra what that means in
detail I will go over in a minute this
is also used for fitting of discrete
nonlinear models such as reversible
associations non ideality Co segmenting
solvents and Mars and other complicated
systems then we have a Monte Carlo
analysis which allows us to extract the
statistics of the parameter
distributions that we measure and allow
us to assign things like how much a on
how much example our samples parameters
are distributed and then our we have van
hold write analysis which gives us very
detailed on sedimentation diffusion
corrected sedimentation profiles which
allow us then to compare samples let's
say in different conditions different
ionic strength different pH and get even
slight differences with great resolution
on there also other methods such as the
C of s and the C of s comma F away of 0
and so forth that are implemented in
other other software packages these are
rather low resolution em we we generally
don't use an altar stamp so here's an
illustration of the problem that we're
trying to solve that if you have a
mixture of different sizes and shapes in
a solution then what you would like to
know is where are they so if you have a
two-dimensional space here which arm
maps out the shape let's say on the
y-axis and the size on the x-axis you
could imagine that you have a molecule
that's very globular with the frictional
ratio close to Y and the small size in
the lower-left here at that blue dot and
the shape of that curve would look like
on
the pattern that you see above which is
very closely spaced on boundaries
because it's smaller settlements slowly
but it spreads out very rapidly it has
large diffusion because it's very
globular in contrast to that you can
have something that is very elongated
and very large which would settlement
very rapidly because of the large size
and so the boundaries would be spaced
far apart and you would get on steep
boundaries because of the elongated
shape the diffusion would be very slow
and so you would see something like in
the upper right and then you can have
intermediate cases in between and then
the question is how much of each of
these components do you have so we would
then for each dot on that we find in our
mixture representing one saw solute or
one analyte we would then need to know
what the partial concentration of that
is so after we do our analysis we end up
with a arm with a picture that sort of
looks like this where um we can
represent the partial concentration of
each analyte that we find by a color
density so a faint color would represent
low concentration and an intense color
would represent high concentration this
can also be shown in three dimensional
plot like you see here where the height
of the peak represents the concentration
now you will also see me show
distributions on from the manhole budget
analysis which can be either represented
in cyan and integral distributions where
you can read up to the y-axis on the
relative proportion in percentage and
from the x-axis you get the amount or
the size arm or the sedimentation
coefficient at which the relative amount
is sedimenting so here we see like four
or five different components that
sediment at different speeds and have
different relative amounts you can also
show this as a differential distribution
shown in green which looks more like a
chromatogram you might be used to
but the nice thing about the integral
distribution is that you can go
immediately to the y-axis and read off
the amount of material that might be
there so are a correct explanation of
the two-dimensional spectrum analysis
you simply take this two-dimensional
grid that we have and you solve the Lamb
equation for each one of those grid
points so each grid point of course
represents a different sedimentation and
diffusion pair and so we solve it for
all of them and knowing the frictional
coefficient at each point we can plug
that in together with the sedimentation
coefficient to get the diffusion
coefficient so we have a diffusion
coefficient and sedimentation
coefficient that we can plug in to our
lamb equation to simulate and now our
question is simply how much of each
component do we need which is shown down
here in the Sun and then we subtracted
from our experimental data and we're
trying to make that difference minimum
so that's called least squares fit and
if you have satisfied this minimization
then the amplitudes for each individual
component will tell us how much of each
species is in our mixture is there we
use a process called n NL s are non
negatively constraint least squares
which guarantees that these amplitudes
either positive or zero zero if the
sample or the analyte isn't present then
the amplitude would simply be 0 and if
it is present it will be it will be a
little bit arm you know positive so to
get high resolution we move the squid
around until we have whatever desired
resolution we we need and we save the
positives are contributions in the
storage grid here
which then becomes our answer this can
be done in parallel you simply take each
grid moving and put it into a different
processor and calculate them all at the
same time you collect the results into a
final brit which will give you the
answer in the next step you might refine
the solution so here you see a
of what you might get back from the TD
essay and you draw a box around each
solute that was found and then you use
the genetic algorithms to evolve a
solution that will then also filter out
solutes that may not be there or may
actually be just noise and false
positives so this is called parsimonious
regularization and it's achieved by the
genetic algorithm and all of this cleans
done on supercomputer this is the
genetic algorithm solution them that you
might get from the previous two days a
distribution so you can see we end up
with much fewer component in this
solution satisfies our comms razor
meaning the simplest solution that gives
you the same are masti or quality of fit
is the best solution this is the one
that we really want
so we filtered out all the noise in the
noise contributions and it's false
positives and we get rid of them by
genetic algorithms which figured out
which are the salient components that we
really have in the system and again this
is done on the supercomputer all of this
is done with the ultra scan software arm
using the Exede environment which is an
NSF funded the supercomputing
environment are called extreme science
and engineering-- discovery environment
and we have this ultra scan science
gateway which is supported by NSF which
allows each institution that has an
elliptical ultracentrifuge
to have their own instance and then run
these analyses on the exceed
infrastructure and it's all free so if
you have an analytical
ultracentrifugation you put and
high-resolution analysis on there are
several supercomputers across the United
States that we use and we also have an
implementation in Germany that that
serves Europe and the Middle East
and so on this is distributed and in
production use on pretty much worldwide
so let's look at another message here on
the parametrically constraint spectrum
analysis so this is a very simple system
we just mix two analytes together in
this case we have a globular protein of
about fourteen point three kilovolt
lysozyme we mix it with a 208 base pair
DNA fragment which is a extended linear
double-stranded DNA thread and the
question we would ask them as can we get
a good description of this uh
heterogeneity in size and shape using an
analysis method that is pretty simple to
do um so one of the low resolution
methods that exists that would give us a
univariate
parametrization meaning one s value for
one shape is the C of s it basically
uses the horizontal line to represent
the sedimentation space and then move
that line up and down in the frictional
ratio domain to find the best possible
fit so if you have two different on
anisotropies and begin in and protein
here then what we would have is a weight
average frictional ratio that would then
represent both of these but it wouldn't
really represent the true frictional
ratio of each species if you use the two
dimensional spectrum analysis you see
this result shown you on the left you
can clearly see that the different
anisotropies are well represented by
this by this approach but you still get
quite a few signals returned due to the
uncertainty of the measurement and on
but much better than with the CFS you
get on the the true anisotropy
represented this is the same picture
shown in on in the differential form in
so on if we use a genetic algorithm
analysis we can then do this
parsimonious regularization and really
pin it down unto on the two actual so
needs that are really there on this is
really nice but unfortunately there's
also computation they expend
it takes quite a bit of time and you
need to run through the soil refinement
process so we're wondering if there's a
better way to do that and so what is one
instead of using the CFS analysis which
uses the horizontal line simply use the
sloped line and did the on
representation of all the sedimentation
coefficients that are possible on the
sloped line that actually goes right
through those two solutes that would
give us a general method on that
provides a univariate relationship on
between size and shape and this was
published last year if you're interested
you can look it up on how it's done
exactly but let me just show you some of
the results here that that or how this
approach works
so this piece ESA approach then selects
any single valued function like a
straight line hyperbolic functions
increasing decreasing sigmoids
exponential growth you pretty much can
do whatever you want R as long as it's
single valued and then generate a
discrete grid of these functions by
varying the function parameters for
example you might want to change the
slope of the line you might want to
change the intercept of the line to
cover the entire space in each line
would be discretized across a
sedimentation and diffusion on the two
dimensional parameter space and optimize
with in-the-know s so here are some
examples of the functions you could use
to cover the entire two dimensional
space of s and D or size and shape so in
the upper left you see a straight line
parameterization on the upper right you
see increasing sigmoid on the lower on
center you see a decreasing sigmoid if
you fit this particular sample of
lysozyme in DNA was a PC si we get this
result and so here you see all the
different lines shown in different
colors and the colors represent the
quality of the fit so every time you
check a different representation of that
line we get a different R misty or
quality of the fit and we assign a color
to it
that
from very low meaning a very good fit in
red to purple meaning a very poor fit so
you can see that this diagonal that goes
from the lower left to the upper right
represents a good fit and there's one
line that gives the best fit and that's
the one that we pull out and if you
compare that to the genetic algorithm
result we see that they're pretty much
right on top of each other giving us the
same result so that's very encouraging
so now we apply that to represent a
polymerizing system in this case simply
a restriction digest of DNA in this case
you have many different on sizes that
are on different molecular weight but
they're also different [ __ ] because
double-stranded DNA when it's linear
becomes more extended the larger it gets
so we want to capture this relationship
between size and shape by modeling it
with a PC si along the single line and
here we use an increasing sigmoid and as
you can see we have perfect
correspondence between electrophoresis
gel and the 2d is a pattern that we get
back so if you have very high
concentration analyzed like the two
bands in the middle we'll get high
intensity representing the concentration
and the size in the shape if we pick one
of these on fragment or two of these
fragments and look at them individually
and run them as pcs a again we can use a
straight line to represent those two
components and we get this picture now
this this is a fragment that is 208 base
pairs for the lower one and 28 11 2011
for the upper one so the upper one is
very extended giving us a frictional
ratio of about seven and the law one
about three and a half something like
that in this particular salt
concentration so if you were to do the
same thing with um the genetic algorithm
you would get that red on distribution
shown in the upper right and on
again it looks very similar to what we
get from the PTSA which is shown here in
green now below it you see the CFS
result and I want to point out on why we
don't like to see of s so in this case
for the lower species you would get on
many different species distributed
around the peak that should really be a
single peak but now it becomes a broad
distribution and only the upper one is
actually shown as a single peak and so
that's a problem if we look at that we
see that instead of getting the single
peak and shown in blue and panicky here
you get many different peaks on that
really don't represent this species at
all and the reason for that is in the
arm least squares fit where we basically
force a weight average frictional ratio
that is too high on top of this more
largely diffusing example and that
causes all these different small amounts
of false positives to be put into the
solution giving us this broad spectrum
in the middle you see a line that on
shows the same solution but using our
maximum entropy regularization and the
Lord to see the Montecarlo analysis so
regardless what approach you use it
still gives you a very broad pattern and
if you look at it in a differential
profile you see many different species
popping up when they in fact should only
be one like in the PCs a analysis so if
you transform this result into a
molecular weight domain you will again
see that both of the values are going to
be off in red shown the C of s while in
the PC sa analysis you get very close to
the target target is shown in green and
you see that even the PC sa is a little
bit off but it's systematically off
meaning both sides are both both
sausages are a little bit off and that
is because we had incorrect D bar used
for this
analysis on so we should have adjusted
everything would have moved down a
little bit and then it would have hit
the target right on
so the PCs I can get you actually the
correct molecular weight one on the CFS
you might be stuck with a misleading
result here's another example this one
shows how we can use on the PCs a
analysis to study a process like
clattering assembly clattering is this
molecule that has these three arms
called Triskelion and there
interdigitate to form these baskets and
this is important in exercises himself
so these baskets essentially shuttle
molecules are in and out of the cell and
on this classroom assemble assembly then
goes from a very non globular molecule
which basically drags to the solution
like an anchor to something that is
spherical and in perfectly globular so
we want to then see if we can model this
process of going from non globular to
globular and see the change in shape and
size simultaneously with analytical
ultra-sensitive then a UC experiment and
analyzer with 2d sa we get lots of
different peaks here showing many
different components in there and we
also see that at low molecular weight or
low size we get on very high-end
isotropic values representing that non
globular shape of the monomer but as
soon as the monomer assembles even into
very small cages
you know we very quickly quickly get to
a distribution of fully formed cages and
there is ferric all having a frictional
ratio of 1 and then you can see in the
lower right of this panel on the size
distribution of the cages on all along
the one axis of the frictional ratio so
but again we have lots of different
peaks here and it's not quite clear
which ones are false positives which are
real so if we force the solution onto a
PCS a grid on trying to
you know valued relationship between
size and shape we can use the decreasing
Zig mode which then covers on the
distribution of innocent traffic
monomers going to assemble classroom
cages being more more globular as a
molecule goes grows bigger which is sort
of the opposite of what we've seen in
the DNA case in this case we get a nice
clean picture that shows you the monomer
here and maybe some dimer and then the
dimer trimer and so forth they assemble
very quickly into into fully formed
cages and the picture becomes much more
globular for the larger species so this
is a nice representation of what might
be going on in the assembly reaction and
makes a little bit more sense than the
2d essay here is this a picture of how
well the PCs a solution actually fits
the experimental data in red this our
solution overlaid on top of the black
experimental data and we get a perfect
trace showing very good fit okay
sticking with the Claflin theme for a
moment this work was done by the way in
collaboration with alien life and our
department and she's also interested in
how these class and molecules assembled
to form cages and this is assisted by
intrinsically disordered protein called
8180 auxiliar protein 180 km long and it
has all these binding sites that
captures the terminal domain of clathrin
molecule and then brings them into
sufficient proximity so they can form
cages so we were looking at this
interaction in between these binding
sites in that ap 180 and the terminal
domain of this class 1 molecule so we
took a small fragment that contained one
binding site and we labeled it with a
floor 4 and we were using then the
fluorescent optics to study this
association by following the floor for
let me give you an example of how you
can see that now here we have a on
ventilation distribution it starts off
with in black with just the floor four
labeled
a small 5 kilo Dalton fragment arm
without any classroom added then in
purple blue and cyan we add increasing
amounts of the classroom domain which by
itself settlements like the red line
this was measured in UV because it
wasn't labeled so we had to look at it
UV and you can see that we form a
complex that's slightly bigger than the
classroom by itself so then we can
titrate
more and more TD forty or terminal
domain which is about forty kilo Dalton
into our mixture and form more and more
complex and by following that complex
formation we get the isotherm of binding
and we can derive the KD for this
reaction so here is our just one of the
concentrations or concentration ratios
and you can see we have some free alexa
sedimenting near zero in the molecular
weight then we have that free
fluorescently labelled molecule and at
forty five we can see our complex now
the free TD forty is not visible because
it's not labeled in this experiment so
all we see is the free and the bound but
by knowing how much we put in we can
fill out our KD equation in calculated
KD for this reaction and by following
the arm assembly reaction then over a
range of different titration mixtures we
can then fill out this isotherm and get
a value for the for the Association and
in this case we compared it to NMR
experiment and there is a am on a single
binding side in the second binding side
species as well measured and you can see
the differences in in binding strengths
here and it gives very similar results
is what you measure in an NMR experiment
the next example is an example of a self
associated system where you have a two
proteins that are identical coming
together forming a complex for a diamond
system on Madame equilibrium in this
case this was work done together with
Adrienne Katina clay from UT Austin and
he
during these multi modular polyketide
synthase molecules and they have this
dimerization interface which he
crystallized insert we wanted to study
the KD for this association we did that
by running the analytical
ultracentrifugation synthase at
different concentrations in what you see
are these are sort of half Kalimantan
polynomial our manhole budget
distributions that it increasingly
shifted to the right as you increase the
concentration of the molecule in the
reason for the shift is because mass
action determines that entire
concentration is for more diamonds while
the dimer sediments differently than the
monomer and you get this weight average
shift of the sedimentation profile over
to the right and the closer you get to
complete diamond formation the closest
you get a complete sedimentation profile
just for diamond so again by looking at
the different concentrations and looking
at the weight averages we can then fill
out a binding isotherm from which we can
derive the KD for the monomer diamond
reaction now that's one way to do it
another way to do it is to fit the Lamb
equation directly with the weight
average sedimentation coefficient and
the gradient average diffusion
coefficient at each point in the
boundary for all the scans and again
after you verify that you have a shift
in the sedimentation coefficient as you
go to higher concentration and here you
see a banner advisor distribution in the
lower left for a low and a higher
concentration you can clearly see the
shift so then you know that you have a
mono madama equilibrium and you might
want to fit it and then you get the
exact values for the KD directly from a
single experiment fitted with a genetic
algorithm analysis this is a month of
color analysis of that and so you also
get on standard deviations for each
parameter that you fit it finally I want
to mention a few words about the partial
specific volume that's sort of a
stepchild of analytical
ultracentrifugation because most the
time people just
most the time people just estimate that
value or they take a little literature
published value but it turns out the V
Bar is very sensitive to solution
conditions different salt conditions and
so forth so on oftentimes the V bar
values are actually wrong and so the
molecular weights that you are calculate
are then off as well and you've seen
that in that DNA sample that I showed
with the pcs eight on molecular weights
were a little bit off target and the
reason was an incorrectly bar that
wasn't correctly measured so um how can
we get to this value well there's a very
simple way but it requires a lot of
sample and it needs to be very human
genius and that's in densitometer you
just measure it in a densitometer so but
that's often times out of the question
because you don't have enough material
another way of doing it would be to do
density matching experiments by
sedimenting the sample in simply in
different ratios of heavy and light
water and on by increasing the density
of the solvent you change the buoyancy
term as a function of density and you
can simply look for the point or
extrapolate to the point where there is
no sedimentation at all and that would
be equivalent to the density of your
macro molecule which you can then take
the inverse off to get the B bar so
that's another way of doing it and there
was a paper published recently on from
our lab that together with craig
peterson that that implemented this
approach um another way of doing it
would be to use the question grip
approach this is the last method i'm
talking about and this one allows you to
take prior knowledge from other
experiments that you might have to
constrain the solution to other
parameters and finally there is a way to
do it with using analytical boy and
density gradient centrifugation but
that's very limited and i'm not going to
talk about that today so i will now
focus on the question grit analysis and
show you how that works this was
published last year in this paper here
and on here we use prior knowledge
other experiments that we can introduce
in the AEC fete as a constraint to get
access to the other values such as the V
bar that we normally wouldn't get so for
example if from densitometry or from
sequence or density matching you do have
the V bar you can fix that and then
obtain molecular weight and NS out to be
like I've shown previously but if you
have electron microscopy data or small
angle x-ray scattering data or x-ray NMR
on structures you can fix the NS a tepee
and obtain the V bar in molecular weight
now that's only true if all of the
molecules in your mixture have the same
anisotropy and you can use this approach
that's simple if you have a single
species but if you have had a rigidity
you need to make sure that all particles
are fit that bill but sometimes you also
have the molecular weight either from
mass spectrometry or x-ray
crystallography or polymer sequence and
in that case you can fix the molecular
weight and determine the B bar and the
anisotropy so I'll give you one example
here a couple years ago this paper came
out in it on describe be an ultra stable
silver nano particle and on these people
are crystallize this particle so we know
actually what the structure of this
particle looks like and as you can see
there is a silver core that is then
using micarta linkages a linked over the
sulfur atom to these benzoic acid
residues and these benzoic acid residues
have on the carboxyl group and the
hydroxyl group here on the outside as
it's shown in this picture so inside we
have the metal core then comes a
hydrophobic shell from the benzene
residues and then on the outside to get
the carboxyls and hydroxyls making it
hydrophilic when we ran that in the
analytical ultracentrifugation
corresponding to the monomer of this of
this crystal here of this nano particle
so there is another feature in an altar
scam which is which is called beat
modeling it allows you to take crystal
structure and determine from it the
frictional properties of this molecule
as well as the volume so I'm just using
the crystal structure which does not
contain any waters we can then calculate
the partial specific volume of this or
estimated for the unhide risk particle
and we determined that to be 0.2 4 mils
per gram the frictional ratio is
determined to be 1.25 fairly globular
not an exact fear and you can see why
there are these things sticking out
these benzoic acid religious sticking
out giving it some frictional surface
which then increases the frictional
ratio slightly above one we measured the
diffusion and the sedimentation
coefficient now from the AUC experiment
we can fix the molecular weight because
we know exactly what that is from the
arm from the crystal structure but what
we don't know is the partial specific
volume because that includes the
hydration so it's insisted include any
waters we would expect our partial
specific volume to be off but using the
molecular weight which we have we can
then fit the partial specific volume and
the frictional ratio as you can see in
the lower left here there is a single
species and from that we can derive the
frictional ratio in the partial specific
volume now let's compare these numbers
so from the AUC experiment we get a
frictional ratio of one point four seven
from the prediction we only get one
point two five which is slightly lower
so why would this be less than in the
observed experiment well look at where
these carboxyl groups are the
hydrophilic groups are this is where the
water molecules will bind and this is at
the end of these spikes coming off from
that silver nanoparticle so that would
make it even spike here or more extended
or more frictional that's where that
difference comes from so it would be the
bound water that actually add to the
frictional elements in addition we have
a different partial specific volume
which is slightly higher than the
simulated one or the calculated one from
there from the x-ray structure
so why is almost partial specific volume
higher that would imply a lower density
well the waters that are bound to the
sedimenting particle have a much lower
density than the silver metal so as we
add the water molecules we actually
decrease the density of the overall
particle so now we have a way of
estimating how much water is actually
bound to this molecule by simply
measuring the difference in partial
specific volume between the calculated
unhide res version and the one observed
in a dec experiment so this sort of
wraps up what I was trying to convey
today which is different things that you
can learn from an AUC experiment and how
you can analyze it using our software
the ultra scan software to derive these
values you know I want to thank you very
much for for your attention and also
point out on that other people have
contributed to this research and credit
them on this slide and you all have a
PDF version which you can download in
the interest of time and skip over
acknowledging each person individually
here and just go on to our last slide
here where I would encourage you to send
me on any email with your questions on
we have a facility here in San Antonio
at the Health Science Center where we
are perform a UC analysis as a service
and we can design custom experiments for
your needs we can analyze the data we
can design experiments for you and we
also provide high performance and high
throughput analysis solutions for ACC
experiments with our software so if you
need that help with that let us know and
arm we will help you with this then we
also provide training for AGC if you
have a graduate student or want to learn
it yourself feel free to contact us and
we'll set up a workshop for you um these
are the websites you might want to visit
us on the web and thanks again and I'd
be happy to answer any questions
all right thank you for that highly
informative presentation dr. dimly
you've successfully demonstrated the
versatility of Beckman cultures a UC
platform before we get started on the
quest question and answer session I
would like to ask a few poll questions
to gauge the user experience of a UC so
you should see a window pop up in front
of you the first question is do you have
an analytical office centrifuge in your
lab today pretty simple question yes or
no
we'll wait for the answers to populate
here I also like to mention please stay
with us we will get to the question and
answer session immediately after these
poll questions it looks close to a 50/50
split we're at 54% no and 46% yes so we
have a very knowledgeable user base here
a very strong audience it seems we'll
get to our our next question as well the
next question is for which applications
do you use or would you use your AUC
there's multiple answers are allowed
here molecular weight heterogeneity or
molecular aggregation interacting
systems as dr. dimmler talked about
today molecular conformation
stoichiometry or other again we'll wait
a few seconds to let the answers
populate
all right it looks like majority of
folks use a UC to study heterogeneity or
molecular aggregation that's a hot topic
these days molecular weight is also up
there at 24.1% interacting systems at
17% regular conformation 16% in
stoichiometry 12.8% pets we see a lot of
your basic research with a UC other
comes in at four and a half percent
we'll get to our third and final
question and then we'll have some
questions that you guys have posed as
well the third question is what types of
particles do you or your lab typically
study by a UC again multiple answers
will apply so just go ahead and check
whichever boxes you use biopolymers
synthetic polymers viruses nanoparticles
or you're not a current user but you're
exploring the possibility of of a UC
question should populate shortly and the
interim I would like to remind our
audience to submit questions by typing
them in the Q&A box found at the lower
left of the presentation window hours as
maturity is biopolymers 46.2%
that will consist of your your
okay this is done we seem to lost yeah
I'm gonna go ahead and pose the
questions that we have from the audience
we'll start off with the first question
from Julia we'd like to explore the AUC
to characterize a virus drug product
however there is a lot of literature
found about viruses we'd like to see
residual host proteins as well as the
three forms of the virus is this
possible with a you see what would be
the best that it as a start okay that's
an excellent question Julia let me let
me try to address this on your right
there is not a lot convenient my jacket
my I apologize we got disconnected here
I don't know if you went to the next
question but feel free to cannot erase I
apologize again okay I hope everybody
can hear me
so Julia get back to your excellent
question on how to characterize our drug
binding to a virus so in an analytical
ultracentrifugation ammok behavior so if
you have something binding to a virus
particle you would need to see
hydrodynamic change now this can be also
detected indirectly let's say the drug
causes some sort of aggregation it would
be easy because you would see the
aggregate forming as soon as you add the
drug but let's say you have a huge
nanoparticle a huge virus particle then
you bind the drug to it and you don't
really see much of a hydrodynamic change
because the size difference of the
complex versus the three virus is very
very small so there's not much of a
hydrodynamic signal but let's say your
drug was had a unique coma for that is
not present in the in the
in the virus so virus is made out of
protein and RNA and protein and DNA so
it would absorb in UV but not in the
visible if you could attach attack to
your drug that would make it visible in
the in the visible range um maybe a few
or four you could then just follow the
drug and when the drug binds it would
get the huge difference in sedimentation
which you could easily see so that would
be a way to do it
um there would be one way of doing it
it really depends on the individual case
that you're trying to do that you're
trying to analyze of how you would
design the experiment if you want to
catch me offline later on I'd be happy
to discuss it further with you so now we
have another question here I'm not
really sure where there are but um Chad
do you want to read the next question
yeah I would be happy to the next
question comes from Francesca Matt reoli
and the question is in PC as a analysis
how do I choose the linear versus
sigmoid aligns so I always test both
okay yeah that's easy to answer so in
alter scan um if you run this on the
desktop you have a drop-down box where
you can select which one you want to use
um on the supercomputer if you use the
lymph interface you can actually tell it
to just test all of the methods and just
let the computer figure out which one is
the best one in the supercomputer we can
you know do a very quick analysis of
this and run this on parallel so we just
run all of them at the same time and
then the best one gets returned so there
you also have a drop-down box where you
can make an individual selection and one
of the options is to run them all and so
that's what I would recommend you do
great thank you for that our next
question is what is the best way to
report results from grid analysis
how do you interpret and/or deal with
overlapping or smeared Peaks that remain
after grid analysis this is important
when reporting the data as the size of
the box drawn will influence the error
percentage of species etc okay also
excellent question so what you have is
actually the genetic algorithm which is
supposed to do the parsimonious
regularization meaning getting rid of
the points that aren't really relevant
so when you end up with a genetic
algorithm analysis you should have just
single species however the position of
these species in the two-dimensional
grid depends on noise so when you're
fitting noisy data on you will get a
slightly different answer every time you
make another measurement because of the
noise the noise affects the output so
you really want to probe what the effect
of noise is on the data and for that you
have to run Monte Carlo analysis on top
of it so what I would do after finishing
with the GA I would use the TA to
initialize Monte Carlo GA and run that
on top of it and that will show you how
much these points move around as a
function of the noise that's in your
data and then what you would do is you
would on integrate each peak that you
get back to get an idea about the
standard deviation of all the parameters
that have moved around inside of that
inside of that peak so um again I can
show this in more detail on if you want
to contact me offline and be happy to go
over that with you but that's certainly
possible and that will allow you to
distinguish on two peaks and Peaks that
don't really belong together all right
all right thanks Bush thank you we've
had a couple questions come in about a
UC versus size-exclusion chromatography
or si excess especially for protein
molecular weight analysis can you give
us a little bit of insight there sure
sure that's a very important question so
many people try to estimate on the only
zatia state by just running signals the
nice thing about signals is you know you
separate your protein presumably the
monomer from the dimer and you'll then
see a monomer peak and the dimer peak
and as it goes through the detector
using Moss you can estimate on the
molecular weight however the problem is
that on whenever you run something
through a column and you calculate the
exclusion I'm sorry you calculate the
time it takes to for that so that peak
to run off you can then estimate based
on the runtime how big the molecule is
unfortunately this totally depends on
the shape of the molecule so unless you
have a standard that has the same NS
ought to be in the same interaction with
the column matrix as the protein of
interest you will get a misleading
result again you need standards here to
make it work if you use the analytical
ultracentrifugation
you're not dependent on standards here's
it the results are absolute if you have
the correct partial specific volume that
showed some methods on how you can get
that you'll get the absolute molecular
weight simply from running an agency
experiment you don't have to worry about
whether you use the right standard or
not so in the dish you get much higher
resolution from agency and its
incomparable to light scattering or
light scattering or or column
chromatography just measuring illusion
times so it is on a really big
difference in resolution for agency on
and if you really need to know for sure
he is definitely the gold standard and
you don't want to rely on your column
chromatography result because that's
just too imprecise in light scattering
by itself will only give you a weight
average molecular weight and this will
actually be a very broad peak which will
not allow you to separate monomers and
dimers or get cadiz you can only do that
in an agency experiment so often times
when you have a reverse
system you see both monomer dimer maybe
isn't tettemer all-in-one mixture and so
in order to pull that apart you really
need to use the - centrifugal force
available in the altar call
ultracentrifuge to actually find out
what exactly you have you will never see
that in the light scattering experiment
okay next question
great thank you we are running a little
bit short on time and I want to mention
any unanswered questions will be
documented and will be answered by dr.
den where in text form following the
presentation and posted to Beckman
culture calm alongside the recorded
presentation we do have time for one
more I'm going to summarize a couple
questions that came in here but you
presented several different types of
analysis to DSA Monte Carlo pcs a how do
we know how does the user know which
technique or model to to really use and
how to trust that that data very
important criterion for which one you
want to use is on what it is that you
want to learn and then finally after
you've done the fit you want to make
sure you get a low arm esteeming a good
fit so if you don't get a good fit you
can't trust the result and there are
many reasons why you might not get a
good fit on including non ideality or
because your model just doesn't match
what you're trying to measure or because
you have some sort of a arm gradient
forming underneath you analyzed that
causes nonlinear sedimentation and your
your model just doesn't account for this
so you need to make sure that you really
apply every tool in the toolbox to
figure out what exactly is going on with
your data and each method has its own
advantages and disadvantages so which
one you use really depends on the case
or the data set that you're trying to on
analyze in it yeah it does come with
experience to figure out which one is
the best way to do it but we always
start with the two gsa analysis and in
fact on our website there is a guide
that will
sort of walk you through and tells you
what you can learn from each and what is
the proper sequence for refining your
data set and generally you always do a
two-day as a followed by a DA unless you
have very broad distributions in which
individual components cannot really be
identified in which cases just stick
with the two GSA but we also pretty much
always look at the data with the band
multi-site analysis to get diffusion
corrected on sedimentation distributions
that we can compare very fine grained
detail can contain that way and then PCs
a custom grid those are specialized
applications for the tape glue
memorizing systems or cases where you
want to know the partial specific volume
and I like some nanoparticle
applications that I showed but there are
many many different cases where you
could use either one of them and
probably learn the same thing so again
if you have some specific examples that
you want to discuss would be happy to
talk to you offline and go over that and
help you with that thank you very much
unfortunately we are out of time I want
to thank the audience for their
interesting questions and participation
in today's event I would also like to
thank our sponsor Beckman Coulter and of
course dr. Boyce dimmler for making
today's educational webinar possible
today's webcast will be available for
on-demand viewing through both Beckman
culture dot-com and lab roots comm we
are also excited to offer a pdf version
of dr. Dillard's presentation on the
Beckman Coulter website by registering
for this event you will receive an email
from lab roots alerting you when this
webcast will be available for replay we
invite you to forward that announcement
to your colleagues whom they have missed
today's live event thanks again goodbye